Jim man author of the new Simon &
Schuster book Beijing Jeep why did you
write it well even before I was headed
for China in 84 I knew I'd be there for
for several years and while I was
getting ready to go
I found countless American businessmen
who were either getting ready to do
business in China dreaming and doing
business in China already set up and I
became curious about how this was going
to all work out things were just
starting up then I knew I'd be there and
I wanted to track American businesses as
they went through setting up operations
in China and and moving along what was
the political atmosphere in 1984 in
China entirely different from today I
would say 84 when I arrived was the
height of the perception in the West
misperception really the China had
completely transformed it if you'll
recall in 84 which was the time of
President Reagan's trip to China
there were columns in the Western press
saying that China had abandoned Marxism
that it was no longer a Marxist State
and that China in some way had
completely abandoned the traditions of
the previous 40 years the subtitle in
this book is the short unhappy romance
of American business in China why was it
short and why was it an unhappy romance
well shorten in in Chinese terms or in
historical terms I would say the romance
was from 79 to 89 or possibly even
shorter there really really the
disappointment began to set in by by the
late 80s eighty five six seven unhappy
because it didn't fulfill the
expectations that people came in with
and certainly
people came in with romantic expectation
that they were going to finally fulfill
that old dream of developing a China
market of a billion people why the Jeep
Jeep was really the the leading joint
venture manufacturing joint venture that
was set up in those early years it was
though it was the one that was was most
closely watched it was a front-page
story in American newspapers when the
deal was signed and and executives at
American Motors which set up the deal
suggested that this was going to be a
big turnaround for their company that
that their China venture was going to be
the vehicle so to speak for them to to
beat the Japanese in Asia that China was
going to be their base ABX be exporting
to Southeast Asia all over Asia that
China would provide low labor costs and
that this was going to be the turnaround
for their company so it was because of
those expectations that I decided to
watch it was also right it was the
largest joint venture manufacturing
venture in Beijing where I was living so
in a from the standpoint of a writer it
was very convenient as well who are say
a half dozen of the players in your book
well on the American side you have the
vice president who was in charge of
negotiating the deal
Todd Claire is his name and then I would
say the other leading figure in the book
Don st. Pierre who was the person took
over the and and managed the joint
venture in Beijing beginning in in 85 on
the Chinese side you have a chairman his
name was woojong liang he's a person who
stormed out of meetings in Las Vegas
saying the Americans were spending too
much money were too extravagant then
there was a
there's a Chinese manager named Chen
zulan who came to manage the joint
venture with the sponsorship and help of
the Americans there are other characters
who run through the book Lee Iacocca
made a ill-fated trip to China George
Bush visited this joint venture at one
time virtually anybody who was involved
in in China and doing business in China
in the 80s it's one way or another
visited Beijing Jeep were got involved
in it let's go back to the two people
you mentioned first Todd Clair who
worked for American Motors right he was
their vice president for international
based we're based in Detroit Southfield
which is a suburb of Detroit and Don st.
Pierre was based where he was at the
time covered in the book he was based in
Beijing at some point in your book you
talk about the difference of
Understanding between a Thai declare and
a Don st. Pierre that's right what is
that and you mentioned it about a lot of
American businessmen and their attitudes
about China I think that's right and
this this applies to more than business
but in business terms there is always a
difference between the visitors to China
the foreigners who see China on visits
and the perceptions of people who live
there the the people who live there tend
to become very frustrated with the the
the lack of progress from day to day
China is extremely good
maybe the best in the world of
entertaining visitors and whether it's
businessman secretaries state visiting
publishers whatever and very good at
saying we have certain problems now but
things are about to improve please hold
on please be patient these these
differences are not new now not even new
to the past decade if you go back to the
40s you have the differences with in
Time magazine between
Teddy white who was covering Chiang
kai-shek and his his publisher Henry
Luce and in fact you can go back on this
into the 19th century there there are
always these differences he also
mentioned general Stilwell who was he
and what was his difference with the
American government general Stilwell was
was the main American he was the
military officer assigned to in World
War two to work with Chiang kai-shek in
fighting the Japanese and he came to
feel that that the nationalist
government was not doing enough that in
how often it was holding back on
fighting or on equipment in order to
preserve what they had to fight the
Communists in the Civil War and once
again he came to have a very different
perspective from Franklin Roosevelt and
and people in Washington who seemed to
think that that he had soured on China
that things were about to get better
that that the people on the spot general
Stilwell and his people had become too
negative take us through what happens to
somebody like maybe a Tod Claire who was
based in Detroit would come to China go
to the Great Hall of the People vs a Don
st. Pierre who had to go to the factory
every day what was the difference in
what they saw about China a visitor like
Todd Claire would would come in he'd be
often met at the airport by senior
officials he would spend a week ten days
there he was not naive not he was very
smart businessman but by by the very
nature of things what he got to see was
in many ways what the Chinese wanted him
to see or only what he could see within
ten days someone who lives there
gets to see the lack of progress from
week to week per month to month and and
becomes very frustrated and also I would
say when you live there you see some of
the of the false fronts that get put on
for foreigners to take a very different
example I noticed in in China that in
the three years I was there
environmental groups copyright groups
would often a visits to China say look
we'd like to do what we have whatever we
could to help you improve your
environmental policies we've got
problems with your copyright policies
and it was a regular routine the China
Daily which was the english-language
paper published for the benefit of
foreigners would have a front page story
the day the day the group arrived saying
China plans to do X within two years
China plans to improve its copyright law
as China plans to improve its patent
laws China is starting new environmental
policies and this would set the tone for
the trip that really we know you've got
complaints but things are getting better
talking about a new book by Jim Mann who
is with the Los Angeles Times and it's
called Beijing Jeep we'll get into the
specifics of the story in just a moment
but I want to ask you Jim Mann about
your own experience what do you think of
your tour in China it's the most
interesting thing I ever did it was it
was wonderful for for journalism it's
not an easy place to live I was living
there with family like anyone else
living there I was frustrated with the
restrictions placed upon me in reporting
although I must say those restrictions
were were far less than people face now
I was in many ways there at the most
open time of the past decade how many
years were you there I was there for
three years and when you went how many
kids did you take with you and how old
were they I took two kids
at the time they were one and a half and
and nine where did you live we lived in
one of the main there are there three or
four compounds set aside for foreign
diplomats and journalists businessmen
were not and and are not allowed to live
in them at the time that of
normalization establishment of
diplomatic relations with China in 79
American correspondence first began to
come into China at that time for
purposes of housing they were classified
as diplomats I'm not sure that anybody
actually complained about that it meant
they got housing finally there was there
was was and is a severe housing shortage
in Beijing that's now and eased somewhat
they've built some some housing for
businessman but there is you're locked
in locked in it's a little bit
pejorative you you are in a in a
compound with Chinese guards at the
gates monitoring who comes to visit
is there an LA Times reporter in Beijing
right now yes there is living in the
same and by right same same apartment
same apartment same office the office is
in the same in another building in the
same compound how did you get around
well within China travelled by usually
by plane train trips are actually very
pleasant in China but tend to be too
long take too long for a for a newspaper
reporter you need to get somewhere and
back when I first arrived there China
was still organizing trips for for
journalists that the most common way of
visiting a place was in an organized
foreign ministry trip 1520 journalists
at a time as things began to open up
that no longer was necessary one would
travel either on your own or with a
couple of other reporters even so the
controls remain such there was one time
tell you a story of
around eighty five or six China began to
boast that really you didn't even have
to go through local officials anymore
there were some cities that were open
and you could just go to them and I'd
had an outstanding invitation from a
Chinese entrepreneur I met in Beijing he
lived in another city Dali an he said
please come visit me and I was getting
ready to do a story on private
businesses how small they still were but
how they were moving along I called him
up said I'm coming to visit as is common
with foreign correspondents I wanted to
more than one story at a time so I
called there was an American manager is
is an American management school in
Dalian I called them said I might be
stopping by they said well we're in
recess booked my plane ticket booked a
hotel arrived at the airport and there
was someone from the Dalian City Foreign
Affairs Office saying mister man we
welcome you to the city of Dalian we
understand you'd like to visit dolly ins
famous private entrepreneur and we've
arranged for you to do that at exactly
the time might arrange to see him we
understand you want to visit the
management school I'm afraid that that's
closed but we have made other
arrangements for you to visit our
special economic zone our Economic
Affairs officials they had arranged the
trip anyway it had they how did they
know that you were going well they were
either they were either told by the
Chinese officials at the management
school the entrepreneur or they heard it
on the telephone when never knew what's
an American management school the
there's a special program was set up by
Sunni State University of New York at
Buffalo I believe to teach management to
the Chinese and it is in this city of
Delhi and it's a special program is it
still there yeah I'm a little out of
touch in the last six months and what's
Happ
and to specifically to it since since
last June but as far as I know it's
still there who was the last time here
in China I was there last last May and
June so you were there right during the
Tiananmen Square episode right when was
the last time you wrote a word that went
into this book I mean what was the what
was the last day that he actually did
some writing on this book I think that
was in July I got back I wrote chapter
on Tiananmen a chapter of conclusions
and other than proofreading the book was
finished in in July it's the Chrysler
Motors Corporation think of this book
they commented to you they haven't
commented I think they haven't said
anything that I'm aware of I think
probably that they take the position
that this didn't happen on their watch
this was this was American Motors and
they're keeping hands off but they did
by American Motors right in the middle
of the Jeep project right what year was
that that was 87 they bought American
Motors would you go back to your one of
your opening I don't think it's a
chapter I think it's a prologue and tell
the story of the Las Vegas Automobile
Dealers show sure in the in the mid 80s
and 85 by that time Chinese and
Americans were holding regular business
meetings together usually in China once
in a while in the US the ones in the US
had always been in Detroit at AMC
American Motors headquarters 85 people
American Motors had had a new idea they
were had they were having their regular
annual dealer show for American Motors
domestic dealers in Las Vegas and they
figured why don't we have our board
meeting with the Chinese in Las Vegas
and they had a had a business purpose in
their mind which was let's let them see
what American marketing is like
this was going to be the annual dealer
show that had had the Beach Boys do a
concert they have a rent out a large
Hall Wine and Dine the domestic dealers
beach boys come out driving AMC cars
with girls in bikinis on the back and to
them this was here they'd been trying to
teach the Chinese look you got to think
about how to market your cars out
advertise Chinese of course we're used
to producing cars and turning him over
to the state for distribution under
central planning however what they
didn't calculate was Chinese reaction at
the time the Chinese were hoping to
persuade the Americans to put more money
into into Beijing Jeep they really
wanted to see how much American
investment they can get and how much
American Motors is willing to put in and
the night of this big dealer show the
Chinese took a look at this this display
of opulence and got up and walked out
and the chairman chairman Wu later came
up to the head of American Motors said I
can't believe you're wasting so much
money on this show here you're not
willing to put money into China but
you're blowing money on on wining and
dining dealers so on so it was in in
many ways a symbol of the cultural
conflicts you had between the Chinese
and the Americans how many Chinese were
there in Las Vegas about seven I think
did they gamble no they didn't as far as
far as I know they didn't know and saw
them gambling what did you talk to the
Chinese about that experience
dr. chairman Wu about it and he still
remembered it this was when I talked to
him about it was two or three years
later he still remembered all the
gambling and how much money could not
believe that the American Motors has
spent a million dollars on that show did
that happen in that particular
have any impact in the relationship
between the Chinese and the American
Motors people from that day forward no I
don't think that was a that was a
landmark event changing relations
between the Chinese and the Americans I
think it was it was typical of in very
illustrative of the relationship and the
cultural conflicts that they had at the
beginning of this book as most authors
authors do you have a dedication in
memory of my brother Ron who died at
home while I was stationed in China what
were the circumstances there and show
the audience well shortly after I got to
China I found that my my younger brother
had cancer and for the two of the three
years I was there he was fighting off
cancer and finally died of it was it
difficult for you being that far away or
did you have where you're able to come
back home while you were in China you
know I did come back home once
especially to see him and once as part
of regular home life to see him and then
I came back a couple weeks before his
death so I I saw him a few times but yes
it was difficult when you're in China
did you know you're gonna write this
book after a year or so I knew I was
gonna write this book I thought about it
and I talked to people at Beijing Jeep
and decided to decide to go ahead what
was the reaction at Beijing Jeep Beijing
Jeep when you said you were gonna do a
book on it on the whole project actually
at the time and this this is linked in
some ways to the politics of Beijing
chief in 85 and six American Motors was
very interested in attracting press
coverage they thought of it as newspaper
coverage to Beijing Jeep they felt that
the more they can make Beijing Jeep the
model or the test for what happened to
American business in China the better
off they were because Chinese might
grants some special concessions to them
that turned out to be correct there was
fairly well publicized dispute in which
American motor said look we can't
continue to operate we don't have any
enough foreign exchange to operate here
and after months of tension in which
American Motors finally went public with
its complaints the Chinese did work out
an arrangement to keep American motors
in China because American Motors was was
willing to cooperate with with foreign
correspondents and press coverage they
were also willing to cooperate for this
book when you say they're willing to
cooperate with press coverage were they
which side of this story was more
willing the people that lived in China
or the people who live in Detroit well
originally it was the people in China
who wanted to to go public but
eventually and for purposes of this book
it was both people in Detroit were also
happy to cooperate you do say though
that this was written from a Western
perspective why did you make that point
well I try to to give the Chinese
perspective wherever I can in this and I
think that it's there but I think a
reader ought to know I don't think that
an author should try and be omniscient
and I think it's only fair to tell the
reader look I talked to both sides in
this but I had much better access to the
inner thoughts of the American side than
then to the Chinese side
I talked to sources on the street
executives officials on the the Chinese
side even so there is still a cultural
distance I wasn't sitting down with
Chinese officials and talking to them
with a tape recorder for four hours at a
time as I did with some of the American
officials did you have anybody in this
project that just said I won't talk to
you at all and that that's a gap here no
not really there are some people I wish
I talked to more but there was I can't
there's no one who who completely
refused to cooperate now the on the the
Chinese side yeah there is one official
not actually at Beijing Jeep official
named Chen Zhu Tao who who was a
automotive industry official I tried to
interview and and he put it off so
that's another again that's an example
of not as much access to the Chinese
side and I wanted to be honest about
that in the book tell us about chairman
Wu what's he like what how old was he
what was his job
chairman Wu was very nice polite man his
job was he was originally in charge of
the joint venture and Beijing's auto
industry which means other Chinese
enterprises that make parts and so on in
Beijing as often happens in the
interaction between foreigners and
Chinese Todd Claire person who
negotiated the original deal and dealt
with chairman Wu over the years came to
like him
respect him a great deal let's say the
people in China who dealt with him from
day to day sometimes felt that he was he
was stalling or wasn't coming through
and most of all felt that it wasn't he
wasn't making the decisions that it was
a it was a mistake to think of him as as
the decision-maker because the way China
worked the decisions were being made by
the government by the Beijing
municipality by Ministry officials but
not by the individual enterprise it was
the first time Chinese ever had
automobiles built in the country well
this this Jeep plant was
dates back to the 50s when the Chinese
began making jeeps with Soviet help they
also began making jeeps up in
northeastern China in the town of Chiang
Chun but again this goes back to the 50s
there's nothing nothing before that
there's no certainly no tradition of
going back to the to the 20s or 30s any
way of describing how many automobiles
or jeeps or vehicles there are in China
that that you've either you've seen
around Beijing or throughout the entire
country yeah I think you know some of
some of your some people watching or
aware others may not be China certainly
it's not a it's not a place where where
everybody owns a car far from it
it's indicative that that what American
Motors wanted to make was was a
four-wheel-drive vehicle they could be
used by by work units by businesses and
most of their competitors as well quite
a few were selling vans Toyota sold
quite a few and resample yeah
Shanghai said it had set up a Volkswagen
plant making passenger cars but these
passenger passenger cars in particular
are used by our owned by work units by
enterprises what we would call companies
not by individuals certainly everybody
knows most people ride might ride
bicycles or buses to work not cars what
was the first time you can remember
getting the Beijing Jeep or the American
Motors story in front of you what was
what's the first memory you had that
this was that this was even going on
over there well in shortly after I got
there I guess I guess in 85 American
Motors launched the production of this
Cherokee I went down to the plant they
had a big ceremony that every every year
or so this was common with other
companies doing business in China they
would have some ceremony
to mark a new stage of the deal in this
case it was the Cherokee coming off the
production line I went down to the plant
they had gongs and Dragons and officials
taken a look at the joint venture and I
began wondering then how this one was
going to come out it looked to me like
there were some problems you had
American mechanics who were in on short
term duty kind of mopping their their
forehead and saying we almost didn't get
this one working I forgot to tighten the
clutch on the first one off the assembly
line and that's the first memory I have
of it describe to us what the plant was
like how big was it
plant was it a were much smaller than
than any American plant it was very much
an old style Chinese work unit if you
show up there in the morning and you'd
find women doing Daichi you'd find
people riding bikes into the plant with
kids on the back to go to the local
kindergarten you had banners up on all
the and all the walls with with slogans
that slogans of course had changed it
wasn't it wasn't Maoist slogans now it
was time as money efficiency is his life
slogans of the 1980s but this was in no
way a sterile sanitized American plant
this was an old-style grimy Chinese
factory how many workers well at Beijing
Jeep itself there were about four or
five thousand workers for the whole
Chinese unit which was also making old
Jeeps
old Chinese jeeps about eleven or twelve
thousand one of the problems that that
the Americans had to come to grips with
was that it was way over staffed
with Chinese right how many Americans
work there Americans was never got
higher than eight say you had this
that's right so the Americans had the
sense of being overwhelmed and you could
you go into the the lunchroom the
cafeteria and there would be Chinese
outside looking in at these these these
American executives just kind of staring
in really the I think the people coming
in or in some way hearing about Beijing
Jeep had no sense of of how overwhelmed
the Americans were coming into that
environment how did the joint venture
work how much did American Motors own of
the company the original deal American
Motors owned a little over thirty four
thirty five six percent Chinese had of
course the rest the majority share
American Motors put up its technology or
a value of its technology and about
eight million dollars in equity Chinese
contributed the value of the factory the
plant and equipment
what are these jeeps sell for that
tended to vary the but the new Cherokees
well up around nineteen thousand yeah in
China yeah who could afford to buy them
work units paid for and what kind of
money there were running disputes about
that that varied the Americans wanted to
be paid in in foreign currency and and
usually insisted on it although they
apparently there were some occasions in
which the Chinese would pay a portion in
Chinese currency now again as part of
this deal the American Motors took over
the existing production of old Chinese
jeeps and those were sold for Chinese
currency which is not going
verbal into dollars yen or anything else
and sold them inside China and oddly
enough one of the great ironies of this
whole thing that became their lifeblood
once they got a special deal enabled
enabling them to convert this Chinese
money into dollars then they ended up
making good money by producing these old
Jeeps so you have Americans coming in
with the assumption that we are going to
bring new technology to China and then
years later is saying hey let's take a
look at this deal we're doing just fine
selling these old Jeeps we don't want to
phase that out and whenever when the
question came up should we do away with
production of the old Jeeps the
Americans said no we're doing just fine
with those what are the old jeep sell
for much less
again those prices are in renminbi in
Chinese currency but down I'm guessing
around well less than 10 when you when
you asked about this the sale though you
have to remember and it's something that
often got lost in the shuffle
many of these jeeps were simply
distributed assigned around the country
by the Chinese government there was
still people people would read in this
country they'd pick up their their news
magazine and read that China has done
away with central planning it was a
gradual process and it never went all
that far so even at the height well in
in the mid to late 80s most of those
jeeps were still being distributed
around simply turned over the factory
would make the jeeps turn them over to
the state to be distributed and assigned
to work units all through this process
by the way what what was the American
Embassy and I believe once the Lord was
ambassador at that time in China
American Embassy the American State
Department and the president the United
States Ronald Reagan doing about things
like American Motors and the Beijing
Jing Jeep were they helping at all the
in general the attitude of the American
Embassy the State Department the White
House was to encourage as much as
possible American commercial interest in
China they want to do that for its own
sake they also thought it had a very
specific strategic purpose which was
that it would further the relationship
between the United States and China
China was becoming increasingly nervous
about the idea of a relationship based
on opposition of the Soviet Union and
economics became a new rationale for the
relationship between the United States
and China so in general the attitude was
to encourage this now there were there
was some mistrust of American Motors in
Beijing cheap on the part of the
American Embassy and State Department
Commerce Department that is they felt
when when American Motors complained
that it was getting not a good deal a
raw deal in China the response of US
officials was well you negotiated this
deal
you were you were getting exactly the
deal you negotiated if you don't have
foreign exchange if you don't have
enough money to operate that's the deal
you negotiated so I wouldn't say that
they were they came in and and supported
American Motors they presented American
Motors complaints but there was some
skepticism about just how valid those
complaints were when Ronald Reagan went
to visit China did he say anything about
the Jeep he didn't George Bush as vice
president visited Beijing Jeep was right
after the Cherokees began coming off the
assembly line he got in one and in in
Bennett George Bush fashion
drove it off and said off to the Beijing
hotel it was at just that time that
American Motors was beginning to run
into trouble and Bush didn't get
involved in it may not have been aware
of it I Reagan visited in 84 didn't was
not involved in Beijing Jeep but during
his trip really set the tone for many of
these false impressions about China
there are a couple of incidents after he
left he got on the plane he referred to
China's this so-called communist country
suggesting that in some way China had
abandoned its political system while he
was there I remember being on his last
day in Beijing he travelled through ten
and men square it was May Day it just
worked out that way big posters of Marx
Engels Lenin and Stalin up there
Reagan's motorcade goes right through
Tiananmen Square and a couple of us
asked Larry speaks his press secretary
what Reagan thought of those posters and
speaks said well they thought they were
the Smith Brothers so so you have you
have the the administration creating the
impression that the system had changed
more than it had go back to the plant
again eight Americans most that were
ever there were they all there at one
time not always sometimes it was fewer
than that I mean the most ever ever the
most was eight and and often one person
or more than one was was off on vacation
or home leave or whatever who had the
last say so then who was in charge of
that of the Cherokee AMC Cherokee Jeep
well the American but the the deal that
was negotiated was the Americans would
would have the first president in fact
they went through through three
different presidents first and then the
Chinese after a period of three years
Chinese
got to appoint the president first all
through these these initial years this
d8 the head AMC guy in China who was who
was ultimately in charge don
saint-pierre he was he was a third guy
there were two managers before him but
whatever the other two well in both
cases didn't work out and first first
guy in state I trying to remember six
months or a year next guy another year
or so
and finally the saint-pierre came in
stayed three years about three years who
set the time of the hours for work those
were really fixed by by the Chinese the
the general work dated and the hours
didn't change one thing that did happen
Chinese were very accustomed to taking a
nap after lunch particularly the the
cadres the the officials who worked in
the office building one of the first
things the Americans did one of the
first cultural conflicts was about that
nap so the American the Americans who
first arrived discovered beds in in
Chinese offices and began asking him to
take out the beds finally in frustration
I think one of them went through and
started pulling beds out of the office
Chinese had paper over the the window in
the doors and Americans didn't like that
either wasn't that's not open management
but one way or another
the Americans objected to the nap after
lunch and that was one of the low-level
cultural fights what kind of
productivity did the Chinese workers
have well the Americans complained that
the productivity wasn't high now the
Americans ended up with with some of the
best Chinese workers they were pay
people who worked at Beijing Jeep this
joint venture were being paid more than
ordinary Chinese workers or
ordinary Chinese workers in the auto
industry in Beijing would they make
ordinary worker might make a hundred to
150 yuan which would be like Oh $40
these workers were being paid what where
he does a month excuse me
these workers were being paid Oh
sometimes 200 or more than 200 yuan
which would be like 60 $65 a month
it's obviously nothing in American terms
that $65 a month was a lot in Chinese
terms did they know that the Detroit
auto worker would make that maybe in
three hours I'm not sure but I know that
they make what 1820 hours I had one
conversation with with some workers
where they actually undershot they said
the one of the things that you discover
when you talk to workers in China is
they feel exploited by everyone and they
felt exploited by the Americans and by
by the Chinese it's this common bond of
we we Chinese we know how to the Chinese
have an expression sure cool we know we
know how to to eat bitterness we know
how to do hard work they didn't like the
Chinese workers are young sometimes very
tough very hostile to to authority of
any kind
certainly there are Chinese leaders and
also the Americans I got into one
discussion on the assembly line where
some workers said we know American
Motors is exploiting us we know that
your workers in Detroit they earn even
$10 an hour while they were under
shooting they had no idea on the other
hand they had no idea I had to ask you
know how much a house costs in the
United States so they couldn't believe
the the level of wages in this country
they also couldn't believe the cost
speaking of cost you also talked about
the amount of money that the AMC and
other American workers had to pay for
housing
somewhere did I read that it was a
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
a year for a hotel room when that's
right when the businessman first arrived
they had to stay in hotel rooms and it
was you know me in obvious because I
said this earlier were there only
businessman were there any businessmen
no there were there were business women
as well
there were fact there was some very good
business women there was there were a
couple of of consulting firms that were
we're all all women so American yeah
okay let's go well now we've heard that
I just go back to the bit when the
business people from America went over
there what kind of housing costs today
they were living in hotel rooms that
started out being Oh in in the late late
70s may have been thirty or fifty
dollars a night but the Chinese began to
figure out a that the the Americans I'd
say Americans that all that the
Westerners were willing to pay more a
lot more and that they could get it and
charging 100 $120 a night now that's one
thing for for visiting businessman for
for a week or so but those who are
living in hotel rooms for six months or
a year at a time that would add up so
the example I used I first did this in a
newspaper story and and people couldn't
believe it I included it in the book was
a guy who was living at the great wall
hotel for $125,000 a year it worked out
too and in 85 or so when China first
began opening up apartments for
businessmen the rents were seventy two
thousand dollars a year six thousand
dollars a month astounding rents and of
course if you compared it to to 125
thousand a year the guy was saving a lot
of money by the way you also mentioned
that AMC and all kinds of special
financial benefits to somebody who left
the states to go over there and work why
did they do that and how much was it oh
it's not not on
common for four companies doing business
overseas they would have a some kind of
special stipend hardship pay home leave
they would have sometimes some companies
would have per diem that was what is
often what companies feel they need to
do to persuade to get personnel willing
to to work overseas uproot themselves
and so on they also talk about
cleanliness of the factories and the
country in general what would be have
you ever been to the Detroit automobile
factory yeah what's the difference I
mean did you see any Cherokees being
built in Detroit
no in fact Cherokees are built at
different plants around you but no I
haven't seen Cherokees building in
Detroit
what would these how do you describe the
difference in just the overall
cleanliness of American factory versus
of Chinese factor well what kind of the
Chinese plants are not are not that
clean it just I think visitors to to
Beijing see the Chinese go on
cleanliness campaigns once in a while
but streets are not clean and and
neither are the plants the reason I ask
you one ask you if it makes a difference
I mean we have a fest Didius about
cleanliness and especially in factories
in the United States does it make a
difference in the final product like
that I I don't know I'm not sure it
makes that much of a difference it this
is one of those things that affected the
attitude of Americans coming in to work
at Beijing cheap Chinese felt that
they'd built they built an entire new
office building they called it the white
Palace the by gong for for this plant
and the Americans couldn't believe it
they couldn't believe that it was only a
couple years old they thought it was it
was rundown and old and could have come
come from the 40s yes get a general
question we have about 10 minutes left
what's your favorite part of this story
my personal favorite is the cultural
conflicts that they had within the plan
I've was fascinated to find specific
events where you had entirely different
perspectives or perceptions on the part
of the the Chinese and the Americans one
of the there was a point at which the
American newspapers ran a picture of a
worker sleeping on an assembly line and
Chinese and to the Americans that was a
symbol of that China was the lassitude
and the indolence of of the operation
Chinese said well you know there wasn't
any work to do that day it turns out
that that worker we know that guy his
name is specific worker let's say let's
call him Wong Wong is a good worker
everyone else went home that day he was
hanging around the plant too till
closing time
didn't see anything wrong with with if
he you happen to take a nap for a couple
minutes and a photographer got there
that was unfair that's a Chinese
perception American perception was that
that that their presence and was needed
to for the management of that plant
Chinese perception was Americans are
expensive they cost too much they're not
willing to live under Chinese conditions
they need to live in these these special
new fancy hotels we're not sure they're
worth two hundred eighty thousand
dollars a year or whatever it's going to
be just give us the technology help us
to use the technology we don't we don't
need your management skills did the
Americans the the the eight they all
meant eight men in this case yes AMC
yeah where they all were their salaries
set by the joint company yeah and there
were arguments about their raises and so
on they were actually the the it's
ironic the the deal that was worked out
for them was that the joint venture
would set their salaries but they would
be paid by American Motors that allowed
the the American company to continue to
work out to maintain the personnel
operation to continue to pay their
salaries and and so on then with the
direct the paychecks came from the
American Motors did the American
executives make more money than their
Chinese counterparts Oh vastly more
what's the difference did you find the
short hours were sure the Americans well
the head of the joint venture was
earning over in six figures over a
hundred thousand a year the head of the
American venture wanted to raise the
salaries of the leading Chinese cadres
and he campaigned for it he this was
this was everybody has their own every
foreigner ends up try it or try her not
with their own campaign in China his was
to has set some kind of salary
differentials that were at least vaguely
like the Americans so he said look the
head of this Chinese that the the
leading Chinese executive only earns
less than $100 a month I want to I want
to raise that I want to double it I want
to get it up to over six hundred yuan
two hundred dollars a month and same for
other executives Chinese fought it like
crazy the the Chinese president who
would have gotten the raise being who
was a dedicated loyal cadre a model
worker in the old days and the Cultural
Revolution one of the only things he
fought with the Americans about he
didn't want that raise and when he
finally got a bonus he gave it to the
Communist Youth League so that's another
cultural conflict anybody that reads the
book it's a an up and down account of
the ebb and flow I mean where there's an
awful lot we're not going into but in
the short time remaining I think we
ought to ask you whether or not American
Motors Corporation slice now Chrysler
Cherokee Jeep did it make it is it still
being built in China yeah once they got
a a deal it was a secret deal that was
put onto paper but never made public
that allowed them to change their
Chinese currency for for foreign
currency for dollars once they did that
in 86 they were in effect being
indirectly subsidized by the Chinese
government they may they made it they
continued to operate and they are they
continue to operate today they have had
after June like many other companies had
severe problems not not so much
political as economic severe austerity
campaign Chinese press is just reported
within the last couple weeks while
Beijing Jeep's still there it's still
going how many do they make now a year
they reported now they're making about
it's over 30,000 maybe 40,000 jeeps but
most of those are still the old Jeeps
not the Cherokees roughly how many
American businesses are operating in
China from your research you know well
you have to define operating there were
there were hundreds that went in signing
contracts and then either putting things
on hold or not getting very far the
number that that actually are doing
substantial business in China is is far
less less less than a hundred there are
a whole separate end of the of the the
business relationship between the two
companies is offshore oil so there are
oil companies also operating in China
but but all in all the number of
companies doing serious substantial
business in China is far less than the
hundreds that went rushing in and
consumer goods that we understand who's
the most successful there have been
companies that that went in making food
products Gillette went in there
to make razor blades people going in
there to sell shampoos all of those
companies we're really just beginning to
get moving when the political and
economic crunch of the last year or two
hit and so it's I don't know anyone that
that's it's doing spectacularly well
after you've read your book say you're
one that's caught up in the romance of
having a company based in China even
today after what happened over there
last year
what's the lessons that can be learned
from the jeep experience well to I think
one not to one not to expect too much
the other is not to to to apply to China
the same business standards and business
judgment that you would apply anywhere
else
not to be so overawed by doing business
by by China that you suspend your normal
business judgments where is chairman Wu
today still there in China personnel
change he ended up losing one part of
his of his multiple jobs he's no longer
runs the auto industry in Beijing but
he's still still at Beijing Jeep where
is the former Detroit based negotiator
this contract Todd Claire he has since
after Chrysler took over the company he
ended up leaving he's he's now working
for another company in the United States
doing business in Asia
I believe in China I'm not sure and
finally where is the manager one of the
last presidents of the company based in
China for American Motors Don
saint-pierre he ended up not over a
period of time not
and leaving Chrysler he went to work for
American company FMC and in Hong Kong
Jim man author of Beijing Jeep has a lot
more information about the people we're
talking about and a lot more narrative
on the story short unhappy romance of
American business in China Jim man at
the Los Angeles Times thank you for
joining us thanks bye